I need a whisk
and there it is flying in he's three for
three when catching with
all right welcome the next level kitchen
where we're giving the tips and recipes
it takes to get your cooking to the next
level and today we're getting a little
sweeter it's time for Next Level dessert
My Favorite Time listen today we're
going to show you how to whip up a
dessert and a skillet that's quick and
delicious perfect for when that sweet
tooth bug hits but before we get to that
let's talk about the simple things you
need to start baking yes uh well I mean
I feel like baking is the most beautiful
time to kind of get in your Vibe get in
your Zone and kind of use up what you
have in your in your pantry right what
is seasonal you might have went to the
farmer's market got some Citrus I'm
using apples love that around the fall
time how about yourself I love it listen
you're using apples and to be honest my
go-to at home for my kids is I saute
some apples a little bit of granola on
top just store-bought granola and some
ice cream and it's an apple pie right
all day long or if you love chocolate
like I do then it's chocolate butter egg
sugar that's really all you need to make
a quick brownie or cake oh my gosh yeah
I cannot wait to lick the spoon okay
that's my favorite thing as a kid yes
well let's do that what are you making
you got a lot more prep maybe I do so
I'm gonna start prepping the fruit
basically just quartering these apples
and getting the core out of the Apple
I'm actually Gonna Leave the peel on
there's amazing health benefits there
with um retaining the fiber how much
benefits and dessert I was not expecting
you to say that I'm making a skillet
brownie
uh I'm a big fan of the brownie but I'll
get into it even before we make it are
you uh okay center cut brownie person or
an edge Brown I'm an edge brownie cut
person all day long 100 I love that
chewy crunch because it kind of
overcooks a little bit around the
outside but then you get the center
that's like a lot more tender
how about yourself rarely do we disagree
and we're not going to today Edge I am
an edge brownie person as well and
here's what I'm doing to start my
Skillet brownies I have some baking
chocolate and a double boiler which is
something that you've heard of you don't
want to burn your chocolate so it's just
some hot water in one pan and then on
top of it I have uh this nice baked
baking proof uh heat resistant Bowl
where I'm just melting the chocolate
nice the greatest part about baking
chocolate I don't have to do much and
then I'm just going to add the rest of
the ingredients sugar butter flour and
eggs uh but of course I'm gonna have to
I want to crack my eggs and just whip
them a little bit uh before I add them
so I like to just do I like to just
crack them right on the side and just a
little a little top and then go up high
with it
um and if you want if you've done if
you've cracked many eggs in your life
like I have maybe you can go for the
double egg crack totally and then you
just two eggs at one at one shot I mean
it's next level I'm just showing off and
it's efficient just trying to show up
it's efficient so there we go we got our
four eggs and then again you don't have
to whip these if you don't want but I'm
gonna whip this up and get ready to make
my brownies you're doing well on your
apples over there thank you Chef look at
your work it's so precise it's my brain
it's ridiculous it's uh I don't know if
it's a gift or a curse okay so it looks
like we're both doing Skillets here
which is kind of amazing as well what
type of Skillet do you have I got just
like a I I love by the way this is like
one of my favorite pans yeah just like
sort of like in my house grandma's cast
iron pan that got passed down through
generations totally nice even heat love
that so I'm just gonna get my apples
going really simple dessert um similar
to what you make for your children at
home
um just sauteing the apples and a little
bit of butter whenever I make desserts I
really enjoy adding a pinch of salt that
really levels up the sweetness in a
dessert so I'm just gonna cook these
down a bit and I'm gonna add some some
juice of two oranges I'm gonna add some
salt too to my brownies
just because you're doing it but no I
actually love the salty sweet is a great
great idea and then over here I'm just
this is why I'm really really easy right
because you get all your meats and floss
which means getting all of your
ingredients together you know that and I
have my melted chocolate and I'm just
gonna add my brown sugar my granulated
sugar uh my flour and my butter uh and
uh it's pretty simple with brownies you
really just have to add all of this
stuff right it's really just one sort of
uh I don't know
dump and stir which sounds horrible but
really like it's just it's just an easy
easy Little Mix love that
so I'm just going to add a little bit of
the orange zest as well getting those
natural oils and depth of flavor love
that how many cups going on I have all
of my ingredients in my brownies I have
the flour I have the sugar and I'm just
going to lightly mix all of that and
then I'm melting some butter I'm gonna
add that to the brownie mixture and then
that's the batter for my brownies I have
the the cast iron that's that's heating
up I'm gonna put my batter inside that
cast iron and then I want a little bit
of garnish so up here on the top I'm
just starting a nice little basic
caramel it's lovely sugar melted in a
pan as easy as can be love it um you
want to be careful when you're melting
sugar you're making caramel at home
because it's it's the it's you gotta be
careful with it it's really really hot
and sugar will stick to you and as we
all know with chefs it's like the worst
burn that you could get right ah so bad
so as your butter is melting your sugar
is caramelizing I'm just going to add a
little bit of depth of flavor by some
warm baking spices just spices that you
generally see in fall or winter tiny bit
of clothes of
a little bit of cinnamon
and all of those wintry spices that
we're always thinking about absolutely
and touch of nutmeg okay here we go I
have my butter now I have my chocolate I
have my flour my sugar I'm gonna add a
little bit of vanilla extract as well
you don't have to be so precise with
this I'll just do a little Cap's worth
um but this is a nice little way you
know what we don't extract I love the uh
almond actually oh love almond extracts
one of my favorites okay there's my
batter I have that wow that came
together so quick did come together
really really quick so again that's the
best part about this right A lot of
people get intimidated by desserts
thinking that totally you know it takes
a lot of time to make totally so we have
our eggs whipped into our chocolate we
have our cast iron throw a little bit of
butter in there so that this is not
going to stick to the bottom yum your
apples smell absolutely amazing thank
you yeah they're starting to release
that pectin get nice and gooey
and then it's real simple here this
luscious brownie batter cooked in the
skillet Can I taste it yep uh you can
there's I mean there's little eggs in
there but you're fine but you're you're
fine with a classic mayonnaise and raw
eggs right
it's the best part the best part licking
the spoon kidding me
I'll put a little bit of chopped pecans
in here you can add whatever nut you
want yeah walnuts would be great I don't
do peanuts in my house we have an
allergy oh wow all right and then I'm
just going to pop that into the oven
all right so that's got a bake what are
you gonna do you have to bake yours um
it just actually needs to warm through
the apples are pretty cooked I have some
brown sugar I have some flour I have
some oats I'm just going to fold in some
butter and just kind of um lightly mix
This Together crumble a cobbler if you
will exactly and um really beautiful
element that plays nicely with the
orange is some cranberry so I just kind
of fold that in doesn't need to cook at
all orange cranberry right I love it
okay I have a little bit of caramel now
that's just at the right point I'm gonna
add some cream you can add some butter
I'm just gonna do butter here yeah that
smells doesn't that smell amazing it's
giving butterscotch Vibes so I just kind
of break up the butter a little bit just
to lubricate the oats
I love it so listen I even got another
hack for your dish tell me like I mean
you have that amazing crumble batter
right there yeah but if you just buy
granola just store-bought granola right
on top of that pop that into the oven
with a little bit of butter it's gonna
give the same exact Vibe it will be the
same it will be the same okay there we
go
all right and you don't have You Are
Gonna Bake yours yeah I'm just gonna
basically bake it a bit to uh warm
through and melt the butter and allow
the oats to toast uh just a little bit
love it and so the apples will continue
to kind of give off that juice and that
oat crumble is really just there to kind
of soak up all those delicious bits
so yeah this is going to go into the
oven
to whipped cream land whipped cream land
yes I love whipped cream right buy me a
ticket please so in whipped cream land I
mean it cannot just be all healthy oats
and apples I have to go a little bit
indulgent with some luxurious heavy
cream and so I'm gonna do a handmade
whip
um
I love it I love it with a little bit of
uh nutmeg a little kind of warm baking
your favorite one of your favorite
spices I mean whenever I see milk or
cream I like to use nutmeg
and then it's on right I always get
tasked with doing this at home just
because you got the guns you got that a
little bit a little bit of the guns for
it but I love that it's one of those
things too why buy whippers why buy
whipped cream it's literally the easiest
thing on the planet easiest thing to me
also hack Make it in a mason jar just
throw the whipped cream in Shake It Up
my gosh I love that I have so many mason
jars you know what I mean and then it's
already in the storage container like do
less
yes you don't and you're not even
cleaning up that's what I'm saying
that's fantastic yeah right all right
you're gonna do whipped cream I feel
like I need I have caramel yeah that
works oh that looks great caramel yeah
it came out better than I thought better
than I thought we'll have a nice drizzly
caramel on top of this
keep that nice and warm you got the
whipped cream I love how you got the
classics classic figure eights in the
whipped cream I mean why do one
revolution when you can do two amazing
right so naisha's making those figure
eights in there really aerating and
whipping the air into the fat that's
what's really really happening and if
you wanted to be done as quick as
possible cold Bowl cold whisk 100 Cold
Cream so go right out of the fridge with
it as the cream warms up then it's going
to make it harder to whip exactly and
once it starts together look that's
that's my favorite part aim and like
listen you don't need don't over whip
your cream no it doesn't need to like do
much more right because if you keep
whipping it then it becomes
butter so yeah easy peasy what else we
got Chef how are these doing down here
okay here we go you got oh wow wow all
right great
he's going to come out pretty much
same time here so look at this yum
looking pretty fantastic a skillet
brownie I got my caramel sauce yum yum
oh yes you gotta be kidding me we're
ready to be a baking team right let's go
uh we'll just go crazy with some caramel
yeah let's let this go all over the
place
right
let's finish up get our caramel all over
the place just let it go where it wants
every couple bites get a little bit of
caramel and then what are you gonna put
the whipped cream on the side I am gonna
I'm gonna serve it yeah I think I'm just
gonna serve this family style and just
put a huge dollop in I got a lot of
people coming over just gonna put it out
there I I have a container of ice cream
and I'm gonna go next level style here
too serrated knife with the carton of
ice cream
see if this works and then this may this
is great for if you're making like ice
cream sandwiches at home wow we're gonna
go big since we got a big Skillet of
brownie ice cream look at that just cut
with a serrating knife through this and
then I think we can just sort of push
out you got a spoon you have a spoon I
got a spoon I got a spoon here we go you
gotta be a team help me please yeah it's
like a push-up yeah there it is just a
big old dollop of ice cream right on top
look at that oh my gosh
there it is that is how you take your
desserts to the next level
[Music]
and more details on the recipes from
today check the description below and be
sure to subscribe for more episodes of
Next Level kitchen